quitter la ville et venir ici au parc du
clos lucé respirer et changer d'air
laura et ses amis se laisse guider vous
avez la chance d'être les premières à
suivre cette visite
donc ne vous inquiétez pas je cherche
encore mes mots après six mois de
fermeture
carole geoffroy ne cache pas son émotion
faire visiter à nouveau le parc de la
dernière demeure de léonard de vinci
un parc de plus de 7 hectares qui
rassemble ses oeuvres et ses travaux le
peintre aimait s'y promener pour ses
parisiennes c'est la liberté retrouvée
de sortir ces paragraphes de changer
d'ère d'être dans un joli jardin
se cultiver un peu chose qu'on n'a pas
pu faire depuis des mois et des mois
un sentiment partagé par carole geoffroy
guide conférencier depuis plus de 10 ça
fait beaucoup de bien moralement
voilà de se retrouver enfin avec des
personnes avec qui on va pouvoir
discuter échanger et voilà partager
voilà comme il y en a relevé
voilà faire le partage de son savoir une
centaine de visiteurs se baladent sous
des arbres centenaires et découvre des
maquettes grandeur nature comme la roue
à écureuil ou encore ce pont à deux
niveaux en chêne massif réalisé à partir
de dessins de léonard de vinci
de quoi offrir au public des expériences
pratiques et mieux comprendre l'univers
de l'artiste
c'est impressionnant pourrait presque
croire que ça a été dessiné il ya pas si
longtemps que ça en fait il était
tellement précurseur un parcours ludique
qui plaît aux plus grands comme aux plus
petits heureux de pouvoir retrouver la
beauté du patrimoine c'est pas trop sur
quoi joue mais je sais que sur le lycée
le jardin avec à l'honneur de voir si sa
maman se réjouit aussi de pouvoir
pique-niqué au calme
habituellement il ya un petit peu plus
de monde que ça donc c'est quand même
assez sympa de faire ça aujourd'hui des
visiteurs plus nombreux dès le 19 mai ce
jour là c'est le château du clos lucé
qui ouvrira ses portes